i i always
admire people who have done soap propers
because and you've won awards because to
me
it's something i could not do to me it
seems like the hardest thing in the
world you have to memorize 20 30 pages a
day and i don't i ca
it terrifies me it terrifies me the
thought of doing that and i know james
franco
got on the soap and he wanted to do it
and he really
you know put everything into it but
was it did you find did you like doing
soaps or did were you uh it was an
exhausting thing to do
it wasn't exhausting of course i was 24.
you know it's like when i was on guiding
light 25
and uh
no it wasn't exhausting and i listened
to the people who had been on a long
time who had a method for dealing with
it you read the script you take all of
your scenes out you put them in
chronological order
then you
look at the week's work and you budget
out okay i have to do this scene you
know these oh no no no because you do an
episode a day and then you do four or
five episodes that week and the night
before you study your week's work if
you're lucky enough the scripts that far
in advance and then the night before you
work on the script for the next day what
was tough was for four months while i
was doing
dancing at luna eight times a week on
broadway i was playing
this crazy character on all my children
at the same time who was peeking out at
30 40 pages wait a minute as you're
doing broadway you're also doing the
soap at the same time
i would go to abc at seven in the
morning
and i'd shoot all day except on matinee
days
i'd shoot until there'd be a car to take
me to do the matinee they'd take me back
to abc i'd shoot in the afternoon and
they'd take me back
to do the evening performance it was one
of and then i do the performance i'd go
home and i tweak all my lines and i said
well how about this how about it was one
of the most energetic energizing
times of my life and i ended up
hemorrhaging the vocal cord
you know at the end of that um but it
was very exciting that character
interestingly enough carter jones and
all my children served as the basis of a
thesis
at a major university on
my character was very violent very
misogynistic and abusive toward women
and how at the same time there was a
fascination with that character and
a repulsion you know and the
intersection of those two things
i couldn't believe what we were doing on
daytime tv then we would never be
they'd never be able to do it now even
when i went back to play eddie ford in
2010 on one life to live
it was great fun but i mean i couldn't
even believe what we were saying
you know pansy ass boys your of a
mother you're all this on daytime wow
you know